hey man it's your boy Friday check me
out on the bootleg Kev podcast
show man special guest here
Friday welcome sir what's up brosky
debut album coming coming soon man
um I mean obviously man this album you
get a lot of people are looking at you
right now bro yeah we talked to BT I
said you're kind of like the new uh you
need the new go-to I need to hook up my
rap album guy right now yeah that's what
it is man
I do feel the anticipation do you feel
any pressure no no pressure
just good music bro yeah that's all I'm
used to doing giving out good music how
would you describe the album
uh Life music bro like [__] to live to
yeah ain't nothing in there that's Eric
there's something there for everybody
that's what I'll say like that's why I
encourage everybody listen to the whole
project it's r b songs
inspirational
afrobeat you know what I'm saying it's
something for everybody
uh how old were you when you discovered
this beautiful voice of yours man like
when you really knew you had you had
like a unique tone and voice that was
very special
uh I was like I was singing
when I was a young and early at church
but like I ain't no like I had a unique
voice until probably like high school
okay where it's like
my voice is getting deep and [__]
so yeah once you start growing up your
voice yeah and it was like [__] like
then you got like a deeper voice yeah
it's like different you know what I'm
saying like that's when I found out I
had a unique voice in it starting to
make music every day while I was in high
school that's when I like felt myself
that's how I realized how to use my
voice in a different way and not sound
like everybody else for you like uh
you've done a great job in a pretty cool
like I feel like a lot of artists kind
of start off as like writers yeah and
they let that rock for like some years
and then they go the artist route I feel
like you've done that in a quicker
quicker way right because was it Chris
Brown that initially kind of gave you a
shot on was it Breezy yeah Breezy I
wrote Wheels Fall Off news right here
that was like the first
I've been writing for like a year or two
that was like the first big placement I
got Chris Brown wow that's a [__]
that's happening
with Chris Breezy and like that was June
last year
right a month after that guy there came
up
so like before [__] knew out like I
was just known writer I feel like I was
seeing your name though you was seeing
my name I was seeing your name I was
doing some work in yeah but it was like
it wasn't like
oh he the go-to writer yeah I was up on
your [__] before God did like I remember
he was really into your [__] like yo
that Friday dude was hard because he's
an engineering a singer oh yeah because
he's probably because he an engineer
like [__] in the industry knew me but
the world didn't know like he a writer
you know what I'm saying so I got
introduced to the world as an artist the
only people that really knew me as a
writer was you know the engineers like
if you know you know
but I never want to be no writer bro I
just I knew that was the way that was
kind of your way to get your foot in the
door yeah
my manager told me like when I met him
he like being a songwriter might be an
easier way to get in
I feel like it is the easiest way it is
the easiest way because because you're
kind of there to help the artist so yeah
if you're an artist you're there to kind
of because look bro like when you meet a
R's and executive label [__]
you telling them your artists don't
really mean [__] to them unless you got
some motion yeah cause they hear it they
hear it every day yeah especially if
they go on your Instagram you know you
don't got no motion they don't give a
[__] even They're Gonna Keep it they're
gonna check your Spotify yeah they're
gonna track everything in yeah they
really don't give a [__] even if you're
nice as [__] yeah it doesn't matter it
don't matter yeah show me show me the
audience yeah show me the audience so if
you go up to them [__] and be like
artist 10 hooks
that's what they want to hear bro like
y'all need hooks y'all need beats I
could do your whole album yeah you go to
an Ender like that I promise you their
ears are gonna perk out there tonight
yeah and play me some [__] so that's
really the easiest way I encourage every
artist that like you got a man if you're
good if you're nice with it start there
yeah still do your artist [__] don't
lose yourself but like try to get in by
writing I mean so many uh grades have
done that like shout out to Eric
Ballinger shout out to uh Neo I mean
[__] yeah on and on and on tons of folks
like that so obviously Chris Brown album
comes out
and then out of nowhere this God did
record which is one of we talked about
this a bit on uh at the BT uh radio room
but like obviously man this God did [__]
is like one of the craziest Jay-Z verses
we've ever gotten
um I mean from performing it at the BET
Awards uh I mean just they're just or
the Grammys [__] see look he said get it
right it was the Grammy
um such an insane moment in hip-hop I
mean got Cali I feel like that record
really kind of
really set Khaled up to to you know be
looked at in a different way
um in terms of like putting records
together but give me the back story of
like
I guess the whole process of that song
because we've seen the video of you
singing it yeah was that in your bedroom
yeah and that was that did you did you
record that prior
like like while you're actually cutting
that hook yeah I made it and you're like
recorded a while I mean it that's just
crazy I knew it was going to be special
yeah like
I would tell you the story like I told
you I was writing for a little bit so I
was in this Pub deal in the a r left
and it was on some [__] like I ain't
have nobody else like I'm broke as [__]
I had no connection into the building
besides that a r so me and my team was
looking for a like a buyout somebody
else should buy my manager Edgar to buy
out your buy me on my Pub dude yeah so
my manager Edgar he he connected to um
Eddie Mary J Blige manager he worked at
another Pub company prescription he
telling him like bro we need to be
looking for a buyout we need this bio
like he the one I'm telling you yeah
like he was just pushing it
and then
they finally buy me out my Pub do so we
fresh into this Pub dude
Chris Brown come up
and then I'm watching Khaled on
Instagram say God did every day like
every time I wake up I think he said God
did like every day for like three months
yep I've been had like a goddess sample
and then I called my manager I'm like
bro let's send it let's send it to
College it's simple he like nah make a
hook like a real hook like just you type
[__] I made the hook bro as soon as I
started like the idea I called my camera
man bro I said come to the crib this is
special special bro like I already had
the melody like before I recorded it I
already had like the the melody not even
the words I just knew where I was gonna
take it
soon as I made it bro I knew that she
was the one now did you get the pretty
immediate feedback from Cali that like
oh this is something like this is but I
know you didn't know who didn't make you
didn't know who who actually made it on
the record for a while right
so look after I made it right we call
Eddie
we played it for Eddie
that ain't going crazy he had Kylie
number texted to college
took back like the next day
I need this on my Island
you know what I'm saying like a week go
by we already starting the paperwork
it's at first it was supposed to be like
a like a like an interlude just me with
the keys how you heard my hook a couple
days go by he like I just put three
artists on here and a singer
he said this [__] gonna live forever as
soon as he said that bro I'm already
thinking like Nas Kanye Jay-Z I'm
thinking all high level names based off
the like the record yeah for sure
so I I I I heard rumors of who was on
the track but I I didn't hear the track
till it came up bro like everybody else
so when you heard Jay-Z had like a
[__] I don't know how many minutes
what was it five minute long version
five minute longer made it impossible to
play a radio I'll tell you that
they was trying to make all kind of
random versions of that song when they
were working at the radio I'm like guys
it's just too long guys this is not
seven minute song is not working the
radio God bless it it's a great record
but
um what was your reaction here in Hope
go off nah it was crazy bro
guest Jay-Z for top three guess JC first
ever she's gonna live forever bro just
normal part of that it's a blessing bro
were you nervous doing the Grammy
performance outside with everybody like
yeah I was nervous as [__] like no as
soon as they told me I was performing I
was I was bitching bro like the whole
it's like a month before they told me I
was performing I'm like [__] bro like
I didn't expect this is early bro like
do you like do you like really like
train like a fighter trains training
your voice making sure you hit [__]
yeah you know what I'm saying like the
week of the Grammys bro every day I was
singing yeah I did like all day
just so it's like by the time the
Grammys come I can't mess up because
I've been singing it all week when I
woke up shower string and [__] I
remember like right before he was about
to perform
Cali came to my um
where I was getting dressed that type
[__] it's on my tick tock and he played
the instrumental in my ear
his whole team everybody that was Jay-Z
everybody outside
he put the joint in my ear I even know
he thought I was gonna sing that was
before the performance and I just
started singing it
everybody like he ready and I just once
that happened bro I just went on stage
with that same energy bro knocked it out
the park man yeah
um talk about like some of your
influences growing up obviously uh being
out of Philly man Philly's obviously a
legendary hip-hop City there's so many
different
artists we can go back to the roots uh
obviously all the way to Meek Mill and
you know the freeway all that good [__]
but like who were you influenced by
growing up uh I grew up in a church so
it was just like soulful music when I
was a kid and then like when I outside
of it I'll start going to like Boys to
Men you know what I'm saying like what
was that dude with that deep voice on
Boyz II Men deep and [__] I know you're
talking about he would talk and [__]
yeah
I forgot his name though but that was
like I hope he's on Cameo that'd be the
Cameo to get like just have him lay down
your voice like your voicemail like hey
what up ladies you called Friday leave a
voicemail and yes this is me from Boys
to Men
yeah that was like my my like first and
inspiration obviously Philly Legends
yeah so it's like
and then it was like right after that it
was just like all r b like Jamie Foxx
Brian McKnight then I started like
living my life in like Meek Mill Kanye
West and Drake trying to I mean Jamie
Foxx alien level Talent yeah different
[__] don't know like they sleep on his
music that first album that I'm the
unpredictable oh my God yeah that uh
what was that song called one night okay
it was a one night occasion
that [__] that [__] man I was I'm so
glad he's all right yeah for sure he one
of the ones top tier actor top tier
comedian top tier singer singer just
everything he's a beast man yeah and
shout out to uh shout out to his new
movie uh the Clone Tyrone yeah right now
yeah it's going crazy so obviously you
uh you you end up
for you the Catalyst to start writing
and like I guess everyone kind of you
said you had a pub deal that you had to
get bought out of right so what was like
your first initial like real step into
being in the quote-unquote music
industry like how did you get that
initial Pub deal like before we really
knew who you were you know what I'm
saying uh
[__] I uh
around like it was like 2019 2020.
that's when I met uh my manager okay and
remember he was like bro start writing
yes so when I met him I was like making
like 10 hooks a week bro like were you
still in Philly yeah I was in my the
same room just in the crib at the crib
make sure you're like cutting the hook
sending them to him and then yeah he's
doing his job he's sending it out yeah
so it's like I was made like 10 10 songs
a week
yeah at that time I was close to my man
produced my producer the new the new zo
and I started making a lot of Beats on
his a lot of hooks on his a lot of hooks
on his Beach yeah and he was about to
get signed um
the person he was about to sign to
they're like who that on the hooks
like you know what I'm saying he hard so
that's how like
that's how that happened with my first
Pub dealership and now when they ask
who's that on the hook they they keep
you on the hook yeah they keep they keep
me now now they're like oh that's the
yeah it's Friday sure yeah we're gonna
need that come over here how in demand
are you in terms of just like artists
trying to get you on their [__] and how
selective are you being with that
because a lot of people burn out pretty
quick when it comes to oversaturating
yeah it's like
I look at every situation like do it
what do I do for both of us and then
they like do it benefit me
or sometimes about the music crew like
in fact it sounds amazing song amazing
I'm [__] with you but it's like I'm
down to work with whoever bro like it's
just gotta make sense for the both of us
you know what I'm saying like at the
same time I'm giving my own my own
my own music yeah you know what I'm
saying so it's not like I'm building a I
already built a fan base so it's
probably harder for you to give away
hooks at this point because you're like
I mean that could that could be my [__]
yeah but I I make so much music there's
more where that came from yeah it's like
I got like 500 that I'm not using that's
why I say with the great ones the great
ones are greedy because there's just
more with that yeah I'm gonna just write
another one tomorrow so go ahead and
take it like it's gonna help us out like
it's gonna help us picture the program
like in like my music like I say
and the music I dropped like on my
projects lost the melody and [__]
it's a very distinctive sound like
so like a lot of [__] I make up like
things that's not for me I just give it
to somebody else you kind of know what
I'm saying yeah you don't fit in my
album so everything I make for me is
like a hundred percent for me yeah so
like say I'm working on an album
I make 14 songs and all 14 songs are
going out
you know what I'm saying like I'm not
making I'm not even finishing the song
right for me and it's not you know what
I'm saying so I got like 500 just songs
that I wouldn't drop right that I could
give somebody sure it's a nice problem
to have no for sure we got to stop the
interview real quick and tell you about
our folks at my bookie man look my
bookie NFL season is approaching and you
know what they just added that I love is
that early cash out let's say you got a
ticket and it's looking great you can
cash out early on that ticket all right
I love it all right plus of course my
bookie's got the full casino going down
and if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg they will give you
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars all right so head over
to my bookie ASAP um look we got a NFL
coming there's baseball you can gamble
on right now and of course the full
service casino blackjack with the real
dealer uh roulette craps whatever you're
into slot machines you could do it and
cash out right on my bookie all right
all you got to do is sign up with that
new promo code bootleg when you sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpom
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg at kingpom.com and uh man trust
me the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpom.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
um well we know Chris Brown's on the
album anybody else on the album I'm sure
there's tons of features let's be honest
but can you share any we need a driver
what do you want us to drop it where you
can talk about the features
we can drop it whenever oh uh
when you when you're dropping the
tracklist like a week before it was just
so good I got um
I got the The veto on the tracklist
shout out to him yeah my man Fireboy and
by the way David O is how you say his
name oh yeah I say the reader I thought
I thought listen I interviewed him and I
watched a bunch of interviews with him
from Africa and they were saying David
oh so when I said David oh he was like
you said my name right and I was like
man I was like yes because I thought it
was DeVito yeah
man you got that [__] afrobeat Gods
right now that that taliban's is going
crazy right now yeah I got them boys on
there who else on there
in Maverick City I don't know I'm not
familiar with Matthew there's a gospel
group it's like a choir oh fire I got
them on the intro they it's crazy over
any rappers no no rappers wow I might I
might throw somebody on like a remix I
had I had some rappers I wanted on there
but you know what I'm saying time is
timing
um
well hopefully you don't like some
remixes that's crazy yeah I like so is
is the afrobeat song is everybody on the
on the same song or do you have multiple
I got multiple fires yeah that's like
that's like my um Second Home like music
wise I ain't gonna cut because I'm
Haitian so
they're like afro will be feeling is
just in me it's the funnest genre it's
like finally there's music that people
can dance to happening like on a
mainstream level you know for sure it's
like the best part of the club night is
when like DJ yeah because people are
having fun you're saying about it's like
shout out to March Madness I love it but
I've been hearing it for like 10 years
it's like yeah I could pop bottles to
that but like I'm not gonna dance to it
enough
so for you like uh let's break that
because because you're one of the hook
guys now who would you say is like a
Mount Rushmore of the best hook men of
all time
who's the hook gods
Nate Dog Nate Dogg is I feel like
Undisputed top number one slot right
yeah
then I'm gonna go to um
a little Chris Brown
yeah of course my little Ty Dollar shout
out to Ty
and then I'm gonna go to at the tie
I'm gonna go to Sanford
oh yeah like not even though he did a
lot of hooks but but the ones he did
[__] everybody all of them up tip on
them right now like I think back to uh
the video of like when Milo met him
artists
and I just remember being like damn I
really need to dive into this guy's
[__] catalog if he's making grown man
cry out here you make a real music bro
like
a lot of [__] be overshadowed but
the music the real music we put in the
back a lot nowadays but when you tap in
like a [__] like Sanford that [__]
special bro I was gonna say like uh what
what was it like growing up in Philly
for you because we kind of hear so much
you know my co-host DJ damages from
Philly
and he would always tell me like about
North Philly and places like Chester
Pennsylvania and just like yeah just
like Phillies like that just that area
in general is a wild place and there's a
lot of videos that have been going viral
recently of like
because at fat Nosh it's really bad yeah
right you've probably seen the videos of
people like slumped out like looking
like zombies all over the street and
[__] out there yeah that's right that's
like near where I'm from a little bit by
the way also Happening Here in LA but
you know he
um but what was it like for you growing
up in Philly I mean obviously you you
were going to church and you know I'm
sure you were you had a a great
childhood but like was it was it I mean
easier or hard for you to deal with like
kind of
staying out of that [__] you know church
was in the trenches yeah like my pop
church was in the trenches bro so it was
like it's not like a you know had an
easy childhood like [__] as soon as you
step out of church it might be a
shootout type that's what I mean but you
were able to kind of keep it's kind of
like you gotta like
it's a rough neighborhood bro it's easy
to like fall into the like it's easy to
break stuff into that lifestyle right
and it's like you really just gotta stay
out the way like
just stay out the way bro like because
it would be like you'll be in the way
not even on some dumb [__] you just be
in the way some crazy because where
you're at yeah just like you're at the
wrong place at the right time so what I
will say like I was always focused on
music like everybody knew me I asked
fried I want some music [__] like you
know what I'm saying like I used to
engineer [__] in Philly produce for
[__] like on some studio [__] yeah I'm
saying so
it was just like I was always on some
music [__] and out the way forever so
it's definitely like a rough City though
but you really gotta like just stay out
you gotta be focused you gotta be
focused for sure so you don't get fall
into you know yeah
um what do you how do you feel about the
other Trend that's happened in the
Philly right now if you think a guy's
like too rare and just like the dance
[__] is going crazy
bro they're having a way yeah they
having their way like it's beautiful bro
to see who's a good kid you guys just
signed
I'm just like
it's like everybody's kind of doing
their own version of the Philly thing
everybody having fun bro like they
brought in like a a fun vibe fun energy
that was missing and that's why like
afrobeat doing what they're doing like
you be in the club
all these songs about killing and [__]
all this afro [__] come on [__] just
want to have fun and dance bro like I
feel that's why afrobe doing so good and
even the uh [__] from Philly like they
bring in like Good Vibes back I mean I'm
thinking like even like see uzi's from
Philly right so Uzi like doing just want
to rock
it's like the biggest song in the club
for like a year yeah it's like just this
fun song like
fun music bro and them regular [__]
too From The Trenches too so like don't
get it like you know what I'm saying
like them they just decide yeah they
focusing on the right [__] like we don't
gotta be on those Street [__] making
songs about violence and all that they
just having fun bro did you ever like uh
tap in with like uh like obviously prior
to your generation but did you ever dive
into any of the roots of music back from
back in the day
uh uh a little bit like black thought's
one of the greatest rappers that ever
walk on the planet you know I wasn't
really on that but I wasn't on that
though but I'm familiar like I know
they're Legends you got a [__] Quest
love haven't played drums on a song or
something I know Questlove you nice to
sit on the drums just like yo be an
honor man come and play drums on this
yeah just for Philly yeah for sure
but I wasn't really on them early like I
mean you weren't on them early because
you also weren't alive exactly because
being on them early would have been you
were listening to them
because I think their first album was
like 92. yeah
a lot of and that album isn't even on
Spotify you got to buy it like on a a
real the real jump yeah it's like yeah
and then you know Scott Storage yeah
focused he was in the roots for real
that's crazy I knew that somebody told
me that that's what started in the roots
yeah Legend you got to get with storage
man have you gotten in with him yet no
not yet he's a legend though let him
tell you some stories now I know he got
some crazy ass the craziest ever
any girl that you think of when I say
this to you right now that pops in your
head
he is true he [__] everybody first so
whatever girls just popped up in your
head yep then everybody everybody
we gotta sit down with skorts gotta go
out to Miami he's going when I heard he
went stupid when he was up and then he
went down but he's back up you back up
right now though yeah he got through it
I heard that story like he used to snack
the amount of money Scott Storage was
spending on just like everything was
just in I mean Jesus Christ God bless
that guy I'm just a legend his cousin
Mark [__] with squish we be having a
argument like who better Timbo or Scorch
I'll be going with Timber
Timberlands
I think it's like Timberland's like top
three ever so his range is insane
he can do Bubba Sparks he could do it I
mean he could do it Nelly Furtado like
that's why he my favorite yeah the the
range of uh of him is insane how you
have you heard anybody try to make an AI
version of yourself yet
no I'm waiting it's gonna happen yeah
I'm waiting I want to hear it though
like yeah like can AI nail your your
tone you know
I mean ain't nothing some others crazy
[__] they are Ellen Rihanna Kanye the
Rihanna Tim's remix that [__] crazy it's
a fire yeah
I seen some other [__] it was a
I think it was Kanye Franco Kanye single
Frank Ocean joke no Kanye Sunday Justin
Bieber jump
yeah that [__] was crazy though
yeah it's kind of crazy the AI thing is
getting a little it's getting a little
sketch I hope they I hope they shut that
[__] down though they're not going to
the labels are going to start [__]
doing the same [__] the actors are doing
you see why the actors are on strike
yeah cause they're trying to slide in a
little artificial intelligence into the
movies yeah so like extras like they
want the extras to be like AI like they
want to be able to scan like an actor
and then use their artificial likeliness
is coming bruh [__] just be a few more
years
I think some bull made a song like Drake
featuring The Weekend that [__] hit like
a million the first time oh yeah yeah
this was like
yeah this was like what maybe like six
months ago seven months yeah it was
recent and that [__] was that [__] went
viral they like this [__] hard because
it's like also not a bad idea if you're
a writer I wonder if it's a terrible
idea to like writers on there right now
right is doing all AI [__] cause like
this is what this is like let me send
this out so like my thing is if you're a
writer and you write a song for Drake do
you send the AI Drake version to his
team so he's like look this is how he
would sound I've seen some [__] like I I
don't link with somebody they got some
[__] I can imagine man like they're not
even writing they ain't voice no more
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at Odd Socks baby
shout out to Odd Socks man the most
comfortable socks in the world Listen
they got all the licenses if you love
chips you know what I'm saying they got
the Funyuns they got the goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather was double by Odd
Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
can put on your feet but they also just
introduce their draws that's right we
got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsocksofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction or maybe your thing
ain't thinging like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you're asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thanking me your girl will be thanking
me your dick will be thanking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview are you uh your
your process you're are you straight
Melody then punch in or yeah yeah I'm
mentally punching in yeah or a melody
and just think punching Pro Tools guy
when you recording yourself logic yeah
wow we just this guy just switched over
to logic right here
I've been on there for like 10 years and
you don't need a license you don't need
a [__] little USB thingy yeah logic a
lot much Logic the one much easier to
get cracked yeah yeah yeah I got a [__]
here Cricket if you're interested in
this in stealing software logic much
easier to steal than protein no for sure
100 man
um all right so the album's coming out
win
August 25th that's very soon yeah that's
two weeks away three weeks away [__]
what do you say the seventh yeah like
three weeks what is today bro the 11th
holy [__] dog I see like my whole life
is good I have no idea what's going on
anywhere today's the fourth all right
yeah three weeks away the debut album
I'm very excited for it debut album man
yeah uh a lot of people looking forward
to this man I know it's gonna touch a
lot of people too bro have you picked
the next single yet obviously the Chris
Brown song is going crazy but have you
guys picked the next thing or you're
gonna let the face we dropped another
one like we dropped a single two weeks
ago that was that's when it comes to you
who's on that wasn't that one that was
just you okay I didn't hear that so the
Chris Brown jumped and we dropped when
it comes to you it's going crazy right
now the video is going crazy and you
know what's gonna happen when the album
comes out you guys are gonna see them
streams go up or whatever record and
that's usually I feel like that's kind
of the new way to
you throw out the singles and then you
put the album in that the fans kind of
gravitate towards yeah especially with
these bigger artists now the labels will
hit me and they'll be like hey which
song Do you like on the album that just
came out with no note like Utopia right
like no one likes Kpop probably the
worst song in the album I think you're
crazy it is the worst song on the album
it's not a terrible song I love Utopia
but it's like if you're gonna go with a
record you gotta go with the Meltdown
right
to each his own what's your favorite do
you like well first of all what are your
thoughts on Utopia
the great album great production
yeah I liked it yeah I I like it yeah
what was your what's your album of the
year so far this year besides you can't
say great question don't say yourself
album of the year
I'm gonna go on my phone
because the narrative is it's been a
pretty rough year for music it's been a
crazy year not the best year
I'm gonna have to go on some Afro beat
[__] probably a sake okay yeah I'll be
on the afro [__]
hip-hop is like like you said it's been
I don't feel like [__]
[__] not focused no more how they used
to be like that's why in my opinion the
best album of the year so far is killer
Mike's album I heard that [__] was crazy
and somebody played me that John too
it's a joint Andre 3000 on there killer
Mike's future hard yep Andre 3000. she
also worked on that album for like four
years so that's I mean listen based off
that song alone bro
production
Cadence real music bro and that's like
I'm saying like
that music is not being pushed in front
of the the [__] like he dropped the
album of the year I think he's doing
some rap [__] when I listen yeah but
it's like so much [__] be put in
front of our face the real music get
pushing it back bro like you know what
I'm saying so
I feel like [__] Gotta start
back I feel like back then bro
all the all the um the [__] that was put
in front of our face it has some like
it's structure to us right right you
know what I'm saying like 50 Cent these
[__] was making hooks that everybody
could sing bro like listen I'm gonna get
your take because you're a songwriter
right I'll I feel for whatever reason
right now like the women in hip-hop are
like the only people who are really kind
of applying themselves and trying to
make real records and I don't know if
that's because
you know they're in with more riders or
they they're they're trying I just feel
like women are making the most palatable
records with structure with hooks with
like Melodies like it just
I feel like they're really running
circles around uh male artists right now
in terms of just like when you turn the
radio on like I didn't have it anyway
yeah yeah like the chicks are killing it
I should just shout out to sexy red dog
uh she have no way like
I I think they killing it more because
they being themselves type [__] they're
not trying too hard
being them and just you know what I'm
saying even you they raw version of
themselves I also think women are very
like uh for whatever reason a lot of
women artists are like extremely open to
like bringing in help for melodies for
hooks I'm not saying for verses but you
know no men are and you the [__] is
too
yeah I mean but you can't you just can't
hear it in in the songs anymore yeah
because [__] is just rapping
like three minutes and you're like wait
where's the [__] you like oh that's the
hook like oh bro these [__] just
making these [__] a rap a whole song
and just make the song title as
something they said in the song they
always got no hook and then the hook is
just like it sounds like an extension of
a verse and then when you hear it back
again yes and it's the laziest [__]
whatever they said in the verse Oh my
God they will name the title of the song
oh it's the [__] bro we need a new we
need a new age 50 Cent bro we need
something this [__] 50 Cent made hooks
you sure did Ja Rule Nelly you know yeah
hooks bro like
so when you in the club everybody's
singing that hook bro like that [__]
that's why I think Hip-hop not words it
need to be right now bro I agree with
you man people gotta start making
records again yeah yeah shout out to uh
to everybody out there trying though you
know I mean look Friday the album comes
out on August 25th yeah which is also a
Friday
sure would only be right your album
comes out on a Friday well all albums
come out on a Friday but we're gonna act
like this is on purpose you know back in
the day on a Friday if it came down on
Tuesday we still the joke and look at us
filming this interview on a Friday sure
Jesus you know like we're super woke and
all that shit's lining up and there's
some sort of hidden meaning in that and
we're gonna decipher and let the fans
kind of figure out how Illuminati is
involved in this interview Friday
dropping I'm on Friday while being
interviewed on a Friday all right there
it is man appreciate you brother all
right gang boom hey what up man uh you
just watched another episode of the
bootleg cat podcast brought to you by
hard Dean baby shout out to the family
at hardean don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Harding in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine